i came in the invitation of the first
lady to co-moderate her summit
and it turned into an extraordinary
six-hour event where i spoke to many of
the most powerful and famous people in
the world who all wanted to offer their
help their support and their advice
to ukraine and its people and i started
by talking directly to the first lady i
wanted to say to the first lady just how
inspiring i think the rest of the world
finds you and your husband in the way
that you have rallied the people of
ukraine it's an amazing thing
to watch
[Music]
ukraine should not only be the example
of struggle but the example of
renovation
it's about the attitude towards people
their welfare and well-being
people is the greatest value
the president of ukraine vladimir
zelinski
ukraine has the largest global support
in the history of any country
dozens of countries are joining the
anti-war coalition from canada to new
zealand from japan to us to uk and to
every other country of the friendly
europe we've established
so tight connections with the countries
that allow us
for five months to resist the army well
i'm delighted to say we're now joined uh
with a message from the first lady of
the united states jill biden the united
states remains steadfast in our support
for ukraine as a ukrainian mother named
anna said to me
there are no borders for our hearts
we're now joined by probably the busiest
man in the world in the last two or
three years the director general of the
world health organization tedros
gebrezis i noticed you just started
following me on twitter about 20 minutes
ago so you probably be busy reading my
tweets by the way we have something in
common so i will
share with you when when we meet
you can count on my full commitment dear
elena to continue to help and support
the most vulnerable children and
teenagers who have been affected both by
illness and by the war being waged by
russia in ukraine what is the one thing
if you could really pinpoint one thing
you would most like to come from this
summit what is it
i will
again speak ukraine and
someone has to
i understand how much the whole world of
conscientious people support us
[Music]
we're not going to have a recorded
message by liz trust she's in the final
two candidates to replace boris johnson
as prime minister the united kingdom is
proud to have stood strong in support of
ukraine
we know the ukrainian people are not
just fighting for their future they're
fighting for the future of freedom
democracy and sovereignty itself
americans are devastated by the number
of ukrainians injured and killed the
images are heartbreaking
and yet amidst extreme hardship
ukrainians have inspired the world with
your unwavering spirit
and your determination to defend your
country and fight for freedom president
bush joins being saying slava ukraine
our glory to ukraine
one of the people i spoke to on stage
had come from the front line and was
going straight back there after the
summit
in normal life he's a university
professor i don't think
i've ever interviewed anybody who
sits on a panel one minute and literally
is going back to trenches to fight for
his country it's an amazing thing my
duty and peaceful time to teach
that's my main line of duty in the war
time my line of duty is protecting my
family and my
nation thank you
it's amazing
i want to tell you a little story now an
extraordinary story a heartbreaking one
actually a tragedy salvation but
ultimately hope like so many
tragic stories in ukraine at the moment
a six-year-old boy from mario paul who
lost both of his parents
the two wonderful people from kiev
adopted him and they're all here tonight
so ilya where are you
there he is
come up come up come up
so ukraine's greatest ever football
player
was andre chevchenko
he was the best
and he was a striker which is what you
want to be
so we had a little chat with andre
and he has a little surprise for you
we'll have a meeting we will play
football at the same playground
where i was playing as a child
40 years ago
well thank you very much to the great
andre chefchenkos elia he's the best
player ukraine has ever had
i wish he'd played for arsenal on my
team maybe you're going to be ukraine's
next great striker would you like that
that's a yes sir and thank you to your
parents what an amazing thing that you
did to take this boy in and give him a
new life and give him new hope and
there'll be so many people doing what
you do and it's an amazing sacrifice
that you do so thank you very much
everybody
[Applause]
there were some moments of levity too
from some of the world's most famous
faces
i think we have a recorded message now
from some footballer i forget his name i
cannot imagine what the ukrainian people
have gone through these past five months
but i do know through my experiences
with unicef that getting back to
routines through education and learning
is a great healer for many children
england football legend david beckham
and on the football front the arsenal
fans in the room oh there are oh the
first lady really i didn't know that
really richard gere the hollywood actor
you sang in public for the first time in
your life at carnegie hall in new york
and you also sold your very rare 1999
jaguar xk8 convertible and my question
for you is which was more which was more
painful for you selling your favorite
car or singing in public
mcgregor the actor and unicef ambassador
i wish you good discussions and strong
actions coming out of the summit the
children of ukraine need the chance to
be children again they need peace so
they can return to learning and to play
ellie goulding is here ellie come on
elena
first lady of ukraine i also wanted to
come and stand with you today as a
mother
i can't begin to understand the anguish
you feel as the childhoods of your
children and your nation's children have
been ripped away from them
i wanted to look you in the eye and say
that the world must act now to make sure
their childhoods are recovered and their
futures reclaimed
this must be our commitment to your
[Music]
hey
[Music]
you